مواقع واهداف روسية بطائرة
التركية المسيرة. حسابات روسية
دمرت مدينة ماريوبول بالكامل.
روسيا هي الخطر الاكبر على الدول
يمكن لاحد التكهن بان روسيا لن
تهاجم دولا اخرى. زالونسكي روسيا
وزير الدفاع الروسي ان اي وسيلة
نقل لحلف شمال الاطلسي تصل الى
الاوكرانية. القوات الاوكرانية
يجب تدمير جسر القرن الذي يربط
اوكرانيا جنبا الى جنب مع مقاتلي
كتيبة ازوف التي تصفها موسكو
موقعا عسكريا في اوكرانيا خلال
اقل من اربع وعشرين ساعة قال
اوكرانيا. ومن غير المعلوم فحو
المكالمة لكن وبمجرد تلخيصها او
فيها ان دم هتلر كان يهوديا. بعد
محادثة هاتفية مع رئيس الوزراء
بسبب تصريحات وزير الخارجية
الروسي سيرجي لافروف التي قال
محمد باللغتين العربية
والاوكرانية. وحوى المقطع المصور
لبايدن اخبر بالخطأ عن تسليحه
لروسيا. اردوجان نعمل على مشروع
ان الميزانية الامريكية يتم
انفاقها لمواجهة دول عظمى وهي
تحديا. اما الثانية فاصبحت
تهديدا انيا. وقال في تصريح اخر
دفاع جوي للسفن محلي الصنع هذا
النظام سيكون علامة فارقة في
شبه الجزيرة بروسيا في القريب
العاجل. المستشار الالماني لا
اربعمائة اخرين منذ بدء روسيا
الحرب على بلاده. زلة لسان جديدة
ليدخل حيز التنفيذ. عقوبات
مضادة. بوتين يوقع مرسوما بفرض
الجانب? وهل نشهد حربا كالتي
خاضتها امريكا ضد العراق بسبب
وامامنا تهديدات متصاعدة من
روسيا والصين. من جهة اخرى قال
ذلك سهلا بعض الدول الاعضاء
تعتمد بقوة على النفط الروسي.
عالميتين وهما روسيا والصين وقال
رئيس اركان الجيش الامريكي نحن
كل يغني على ليكسب ود المسلمين.
فلماذا كل هذا التقرب للاسلام
تنشر مقاطع فيديو لاشتباكات بين
مقاتلي شركة فاجنر والقوات
بالنازية. ويأتي ذلك في سياق
توتر يطبع علاقة روسيا باسرائيل
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن على
تهنئة المسلمين بعيد الفطر
ثأرية ردا على الممارسات غير
الودية التي اتخذتها بعض الدول
المنتجات والمواد الخام الى
الاشخاص الكيانات المشمولة
باستفزازات الشمال. وكان ذلك
الاختبار الرابع عشر لبيونج يانج
الشمالية ان اسلحة نووية متأهبة
ضد اي عدوان وتهديد مع تحذيرات
روسيا والصين. الاحداث
والتطورات. قالت المتحدثة باسم
عقوبات على ما اسماها الدول غير
الصديقة. وقال الكريملين ان
الحرب النووية رسالة تحذير شديدة
اللهجة من روسيا لدول الناتو
نواجه قوتين عالميتين. الصين
وروسيا نحن مقبلون على عالم جديد
باقصى سرعة ممكنة ها هي كوريا
الجنوبية تعلن ان جارتها
العقوبات. كشفت المفوضية
الاوروبية عن حزمة عقوبات جديدة
الحروب خصوصا البحرية من الغرب
يسعى لنيل رضا المسلمين مع دخول
بيونج يانج الى مجلس الامن. فهل
يكون لكوريا الجنوبية برئيسها
واستخدم كلمات عربية خلال حفل
نظمه في البيت الابيض للاحتفال
اوكرانيا وروسيا على الخط فالى
اي طرف سيميل المسلمون بينما
رغما عنهم. تحليق مرعب. رسائل
نووية جديدة من بوتين فعلى خلفية
الاراضي الاوكرانية تحمل اسلحة
او عتادا لتلبية احتياجات القوات
المتحضرة في العالم. واضاف ان
ستمائة طفل قتلوا اكثر من
عودة طوعية لمليون لاجئ سوري.
تركيا تجري اختبارا ناجحا لنظام
المسلحة الاوكرانية سنعتبرها
هدفا مشروعا للتدمير. صور لتدمير
كل الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وعددها سبع وعشرون دولة
الاسرائيلي السابق بنيامين
نتنياهو. اعرب الرئيس الامريكي
الاجنبية والمنظمات الدولية.
وبموجب المرسوم تحظر روسيا تصدير
واستبعاد بنوك روسية من نظام
سويفت الدولي كما اقترحت اطلاق
فلاديمير بوتين مواصلة حكم
البلاد في حال اندلاع حرب نووية.
وزير الدفاع الامريكي الفرق بين
الصين وروسيا هو ان الاولى تمثل
الخارجية الروسية ماريا زاخاروفا
ان مرتزقة اسرائيليين يقاتلون في
واعتبر خبر عسكريون ظهور هذه
الطائرة التي تستخدم فقط في
الحرب الدائرة في اوكرانيا شوهدت
الطائرة الروسية الرئاسية التي
دولية من تجارب المجنون المكثف
بينما قدمت واشنطن مشروع قرار ضد
بالعقوبات. اعتراف امريكي.
اعترفت امريكا انها تواجه قوتين
هذا العام ضمن تجاربها النووية
تزامنا مع تصريحات مجنون كوريا
لكن علينا ان نعمل على ذلك
ويحتاج هذا المقترح الى موافقة
الاسلحة المزعومة? ان المجنون قد
اخاف الجميع وسيمضي في مشاريعه
والغرب بشكل عام. فما الذي اراده
الروس بهذا التحليق? تجدد
الشمالية اطلقت مقذوفا غير محدد
قبالة الساحل الشرقي ما اعلن خفر
الجديد مع اليابان وحليفتهم
امريكا موقفا تصعيديا في هذا
تعرف باسم يوم القيامة في سماء
موسكو. علما انها تتيح للرئيس
البحر. جاء هذا الاطلاق قبل ايام
من تنصيب الرئيس الجديد لكوريا
ماكرون وبوتين لاكثر من ساعتين
لبحث الازمة الحالية في
عقوبات اوروبية جديدة ضد روسيا
فيما بوتين يرد توقيع مرسوم
اسرائيل في الدفاع عن نفسها.
واردوغان يعلن عن سلاح جديد
مشددا على حق اسرائيل في الدفاع
عن نفسها. مكالمة هاتفية بين
بعقوبات مضادة. ما الذي يعنيه
تحليق طائرة يوم القيامة في سماء
توفر معلومات سنشاركها معكم.
موسكو تعلن استهداف تسعة وثلاثين
السواحل الياباني انه قد يكون
صاروخا باليستيا مؤكدا سقوطه في
جو بايدن عن الامل في ان تنتهي
الاشتباكات مع الفلسطينيين قريبا
واوكرانيا تؤكد استمرار حصار
المدنيين في ازوفستال. وحزمة
في جامع موسكو الكبير. ما كل هذا
الحب للمسلمين. هل اصبح المسلمين
مجنون كوريا الشمالية كيم جونغ
اون بتطوير ترسانته النووية
والمسلمين يا ترى? تجربة جديدة
للمجنون. بعد تهديد ووعيد من
بالمثل الانسانية والرحمة ويقرب
المؤمنين الى اصول الاسلام والى
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
وقع مرسوما بفرض عقوبات اقتصادية
على روسيا تتضمن حظر واردات
النفط الروسي بحلول نهاية العام
حزمة مساعدة لتعافي اوكرانيا.
وقالت رئيسة المفوضية لن يكون
الجنوبية الذي وعد باتخاذ موقف
اكثر صرامة في مواجهة ما وصفه
لمسلمي روسيا بعيد الفطر هذا
العيد القديم المهم لكل مسلم
والذي يصادف نهاية شهر رمضان
المبارك يرمز الى الالتزام
المبادئ الاخلاقية السامية التي
تقوم عليها جميع ديانات العالم.
الابيض المسلمون يجعلون امتنا
اقوى كل يوم. حتى وهم لا يزالون
يواجهون تحديات وتهديدات في
مجتمعنا بما في ذلك العنف الموجه
لقطات للحرب الدائرة في اوكرانيا
ولقطات لمشاركة الجنود المسلمين
والاسلام فوبيا. اوكرانيا بطريقة
ملفتة للنظر. الجيش الاوكراني
يهنئ المسلمين بعيد الفطر من
خلال انشودة اللهم صل على سيدنا
في الدفاع عن اوكرانيا. روسيا
قال الرئيس الروسي في تهنئته
بعيد الفطر المبارك. قال بايدن
للحاضرين في الاحتفال في البيت
سيغير ساحة الحروب ويقلب
الموازين. للمسلمين. امريكا حرص
اسرائيل بهذا التصريح. ورئيس
الولايات المتحدة يدعم حق
روسيا. امريكا تعترف بمواجهة
قوتين عالميتين. موسكو تغضب
جديد ويطلق مقذوفا غير محدد لكنه
هو نفسه لا يعلم اين سيهبط ولا
يستمر تبادل العقوبات بين اوروبا
وروسيا والمجنون مستمر بتجاربه.
ذوي قيمة كبيرة لدى الغرب
وامريكا وروسيا? ام انها مجرد
لاستمالتهم الى صف هذا الطرف او
ذاك. المجنون يربك العالم من
يعلم الى اي دولة سيذهب. تحذير
شديد اللهجة من روسيا الى الناتو
الاوكرانية تعزف للمسلمين
الموسيقى كي تشاركهم فرحة العيد.
بايدن يحتفل بعيد المسلمين في
البيت الابيض. والحكومة
وبوتين يهنئ المسلمين بمناسبة
عيد الفطر. والالاف يؤدون الصلاة